you know one of the great things about
working in conservative media is that i
don't have to take any
insufferable horrible diversity and
inclusion
hr you know training courses at work
that a lot of people have to
be subjected to i've never been
subjected to that from our hr department
uh but many of you
have had to endure it so i thought that
today
maybe as an act of solidarity because
i'm such a generous person i would
endure
some of this training to see what it's
like
just to see how the other half lives and
perhaps to offer my own
my own review of it i guess uh shall we
say so this is from a company called
mtrain which according to the website
venturebeat.com
is quota startup providing online
education
and guidance on human resources and
compliance topics
among their clients are dolby live
nation netflix yelp
buzzfeed and the new york times so maybe
at your own job you've had to sit
through videos like this maybe if you
work at one of those
if you're one of those places you're
probably not watching my videos but
either way
if you have had to to watch these i i
you have my condolences now
m train has all their videos proudly
displayed on their youtube channel where
they generously allow you to watch it
for free so you don't even have to work
at one of these places to do it
so in your free time if you if you're
wondering you know what you can do to be
more diverse and inclusive in your
personal life
you can always go to this channel check
out their offerings
uh they've got videos on what do they
got workplace harassment they've got uh
videos those are probably good they've
got stuff on sexism in the workplace
maybe they've got some hipaa compliance
videos we might skip those i don't know
today we're going to skim through their
managing unconscious bias
playlist how to manage your unconscious
bias because you can't get rid of your
unconscious bias
you just got to learn to live with it
and manage it right so they've got
they got many offerings in this genre
we'll we'll watch maybe a few of them
today and we'll start with this this is
a video called examples of unconscious
bias
pattern matching so the idea here is a
little confusing at first but they show
us a scenario
and then you jump to the wrong
conclusion about that scenario based on
stereotypes
because you're a worthless bigot and
then we find out what was really
happening okay so that's basically how
this
this works and uh let's take a look
um it's the dry cleaners down on a
mission
two blocks i need the red shirt and
i'll see you later all right
okay we'll just stop there for a second
because
what the hell kind of dry cleaning
transaction is that
that's what i want to know so i'm
supposed to feel bad
because i saw the two guys whispering in
a corner and exchanging wads of cash on
the street corner
and i didn't immediately assume it was a
dry cleaning thing
you're gonna blame me for that that's my
fault no i'm not unconsciously biased
for not taking the dry cleaning
possibility into consideration initially
that doesn't make me bias i'm just a
sane rational person
and i have lived in the world and i know
that usually when two guys are on a
street corner
whispering and exchanging money it's not
because one of them wants their shirt
ironed
but very often sane rationality is
confused with bias these days and the
thing is
it's also it's also this is one of my
problems it's dangerous
to tell people not to make common sense
assumptions
in the world we do have to make
assumptions about people
and they're not always going to be
flattering assumptions like if you're
heading into a part of town
where you're going for a jog or
something and you end up with a part of
town where you see a lot of guys on
street corners taking wads of cash from
random people
and then handing them uh unknown objects
which they discreetly tuck away in their
pocket
it's probably safe as to turn around and
head in the other direction
rather than assuming that this is just a
part of town where everybody really
likes to have their pants properly
pressed
so um this has gotten off to a stupid
stupid start already as stupid as
expected i guess
let's try a new video this one is called
um
this is called examples of
microaggressions in the workplace
alright so the famous microaggressions
we've all heard about them
now we get to see an example of them
let's watch this my hair looks crazy it
looks like a mess
i don't believe your hair always looks
awesome i mean how do you do it do you
twist it do you do it yourself
yeah i twist it myself oh i mean do you
mind
oh oh yeah actually i i do mind
oh sorry but i mean if you're really
curious
about it there are like tons of youtube
videos out now about
natural hair so maybe check that out
okay so that that's a microaggression
i i still don't know what a
microaggression is i just watched an
example of it
i'm not even sure who committed the
microaggression like there was a
microaggression floating around there
somewhere i'm not sure who it's
emanating from
um now i agree that it's weird for
someone to want to touch your hair you
know i
i wouldn't want someone touching i don't
want someone touching any part of me
uh in the workplace and so but but
haven't you just made it a hell of a lot
more awkward by turning it into a big
deal and then telling them to consult
youtube
so you're the one who's made this
awkward it was already a little bit
awkward
you've just ramped the awkward up to
level 10 now
before it was like a three or four now
it's a 10 because of you someone says
hey can i touch your hair
uh no but there are youtube videos for
hair touching freaks like yourself
you might want to check some of those
out see it seems like the response is
even weirder than the initial request
and at any rate how does that count as a
microaggression
the white lady was trying to pay the
black lady a compliment
about her hair maybe awkwardly but you
know not every awkward human interaction
or clumsy comment
or or even impolite action
is a microaggression sometimes it's just
someone being awkward or impolite it
happens
it happens in the world in fact
nothing that happens ever is a
microaggression
because that's a made-up category and it
doesn't mean anything
uh there are more examples with this
video so let's let's keep going
how do people at work sit through this
and just keep their mouth shut i
wouldn't be able to do it i couldn't
physically do it
okay uh another microaggression let's
keep going
there's no way we were gonna make it to
that date no
i have no idea what they were thinking
what are you doing this weekend going to
the beach with some
buddies dude sunscreen
you've already got quite the tan
where's your family from here
before here where are they from still
here
but before that
uh a few generations
from here
sorry
okay um so number one
the guy who we could assume it's not
always clear where the microaggression
is but we can we can just assume that if
it's a white a non-white person
then the non-white person is supposed to
be the victim of it so we just assume
that to begin
but he really is 100 a jerk in this
situation in so many ways number one
they're sitting down you know in a
cafeteria or something
and he's on his phone the whole time so
that if there's a if there is a
microaggression
in existence that's one you're sitting
with someone
there's only one other person at the
table they're trying to communicate with
you
you dummy put your phone down
um but then also he just made a
completely normal
innocuous inoffensive exchange into
something aggressive and weird
there was nothing weird about what she
said because
you know what she means she's saying
where are you from oh i'm from here but
also from here
you know what she means yeah she's at
she's asking about your ethnicity she is
that's what she's doing
[Music]
so what what's wrong with that
what why can't we ask that question
someone explain why we can't ask that
i mean i notice that that you are of a
different ethnicity
i can physically see it am i not
supposed to notice it
or do you want to be invisible because
then you're being otherwise
aren't you then you're being excluded
and marginalized if we don't notice
so i notice i can't say anything i can't
i can't be interested
she's interested about in you dummy
knows i mean she's she's a she's intro
especially you're a man there's a woman
she's interested in you
maybe put the phone down have a
conversation
[Music]
there's not gonna be any second date i
could tell you that
are you ashamed of your ethnicity like
you know the other day someone asked me
they said
they asked me oh your last name's walsh
does that mean your family's from
ireland
i i didn't say how dare you how dare you
ask me that question
no i smacked them over the head with a
whiskey bottle and danced a jig because
that's what irish people do
that was my response so we're supposed
to celebrate diversity and embrace
people of all races
and all nations and all creeds but we
can never audibly acknowledge or
or ask questions about or be interested
in those differences that we're saying
um so this is not a microaggression this
is not a microaggression this is just a
plain old regular aggression
by the guy towards the girl because he's
the jerk
so let's look at one more there's only
so much i can stomach on this but we'll
do
i gotta check this one out because this
is uh this one is titled
examples of unconscious racial bias in
the workplace so not just bias but now
we're getting specific particularly
racial bias uh that doesn't sound good
racial bias in the workplace
we don't want any of that so let's watch
this and see what that looks like
no i'm better than you in 2k bro
i've been playing for longer than you
what's good i've been alive what's good
what's up good play tonight
monica
you made it of course i wouldn't miss
our victory lunch
we worked our butts off on that project
right
am i the first tim and sonia just texted
you okay i gotta
just we haven't gotten to the to the uh
climax of this scene yet but
i need to stop just as an aside and
mention that the acting is very subpar
in this in this skit i mean none of the
acting has been great but this is like a
skit i might have seen
on the morning announcements in high
school that's the level of acting that
we're getting here have some pride
in your unconscious bias skits m train
that's what i'm trying to say hire some
real actors
i'm having trouble getting invested in
the story line right now
because they're they're basically you
know they're they're taking me out of
the moment
with their bad acting so that's a
problem but we'll keep going texted they
are on their way great i want to
celebrate
everyone's hard work on this project you
guys did such a good job
i really appreciate it you bet i'm just
glad we made it
can i get you something to drink oh just
water for now
but you might want to tell your manager
about those guys
of intimidating maybe have the police
move them along or something
sure i'll talk to my manager great
what are you doing what call the police
over those kids outside i'm sorry i'm
not trying to offend anyone but
those kids can just hang out on some
other street corner
oh let's see you see the tall one out
there
that's my son michael we're going
shopping for prom clubs right after
we're done
i am so sorry i just heard on the news
that
someone was mugged over here and you
thought my son did it
no of course not god you don't think
that right you know what i think i think
this celebration
is over thanks
uh oh that's your son is it well he's an
unruly hooligan man
that's the problem with your son the kid
just slammed the woman against the wall
and didn't even apologize once again the
bad guy
is the good guy's the bad guy in this in
this skit once again
they slammed her against the wall didn't
apologize
and now she's the bad guy
my only problem with with the the
hapless white patsies in all these
videos is that they don't defend
themselves
that's the real lesson that's my
takeaway you know
when you're being berated by some
obnoxious overly sensitive jerk defend
yourself speak up
how about saying to her hey lady your
son is out there shoving women into
walls
okay maybe he needs a kick in the ass
not a trip to the tux store for prom
have you considered that if if this were
if this was it was my
mother and i was a kid and i just shoved
a woman into the
first of all if if in that situation
if you're a good mother and someone
comes in and says they want to call the
cops on your son
at least i know with my mom when i was a
kid her first reaction would have been
what did he do i know he did something
what was it and said her immediate
reaction is to assume oh could
he could have possibly done anything my
little angel i know he didn't do
anything
this is bad neglectful parenting that's
what this is
and uh that's the lesson for us that's
what i take from this video bad
parenting but also
don't allow yourself to be bullied by
people who are angling to be the victim
that's the real lesson and also don't
work at companies that make you watch
videos like this
i don't know how people do it that is
unless they're putting them on for a
laugh
so you can all sit around and laugh at
them in which case that would be an
awesome company to work